Newark New Jersey admitting that they
got scammed big time after becoming a
sister city with a fake cut there's an
alarm going off the city's mayor what he
bought was the hindon Hindu nation of
kailasa for an official ceremony
[Music]
it turns out it doesn't exist and the
guy behind it is a notorious scam artist
Dana so this happened in the West Wing
do you remember the show The West Wing
so there was a debate question and they
wanted to know what do you think about
the situation in Fredonia
and the candidate says I'm studying it
and then he sold well that's actually a
fake country and it's from a Marx
Brothers movie and so this is something
that has happened in the past kind of in
fiction but as you can see on Jesse
Watters prime time it's this city is not
the only one that fell for this yeah Dan
is coming on the show tonight because
it's several cities uh dozens of cities
actually that you could be on live right
been suckered into this yeah like your
show yeah and this guy's not just a scam
artist he's an international fugitive
he's wanted for serial rape in India
he has diplomatic immunity and Newark
the entire city council didn't Google as
Don Lemon said can be effective yep yep
five women claimed that he raped them
and he's got this diplomatic immunity as
as Jesse said but here's the question
why do you want to be a sister city I
know you want to exchange cultural and
you know all of this interpersonal stuff
but somebody gets money somewhere right
okay and the next step would have been
the passage of money I imagine not from
klasa but from New Jersey what is
occurrency
um it's probably the roofies
rubies roofies it's a roofie crypto oh
it could be I mean if the guy's a rapist
I you know um
this is Newark yeah yes I mean I mean I
consider them lucky that this didn't
cost any taxpayer that much money
because Newark has a lot of problems
this explains a lot about Newark that
they're not the brightest tools in the
shed and that didn't even make sense the
brightest tools and they're not
flashlights which
tool sharpest they're not the sharpest
the sharpest in the swimming pool
the five loves Newark New Jersey just we
do we love it no we don't do we I know
yes
don't do that one more thing it is Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now